it's virtually guaranteed that if you're
a superhero in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe your family is full of tragedy
even with the stiff competition from
folks like Thor and Peter Parker it's
hard to point out a super family with
more ongoing drama than the wakandan
royalty in Captain America Civil War
King t'chaka dies leaving his distraught
son to Chala seeking Vengeance in Black
Panther we find out that young tachaka
killed his exiled criminal brother in
jobu which sends the latter's son into
DACA on a path that turns him into
killmonger the movie's main antagonist I
found my daddy with Panther claws in his
chest you ain't the son of a king you're
a son of a murderer warning we're about
to get into Major Spoilers tell me the
spoiler's child and embrace your destiny
black panther wakanda forever doubles
down on the tragedy Trend in addition to
depicting t'challa's death a necessary
plot point to reflect the real world
death of star Chadwick Boseman Queen
ramonda also dies during during the
events of the movie after Queen
ramonda's Death it seems that t'challa's
younger sister shuri is the only
remaining member of her family leading
her down a path of violent Revenge from
which she veers away at the last minute
however the movie's mid-credits scene
actually reveals a new member of the
wakandan royal family we discover that
t'challa actually fathered a son with
Nakia as the latter introduces Sheree to
Young Tucson he reveals that his
wakandan name is in fact t'challa with a
name like that it seems like Marvel
Studios is setting the child up to
become a huge part of the MCU many years
down the line still major Marvel fans
might already have noticed that the MCU
origin of the character is quite
different from t'challa's son in the
pages of Marvel Comics bear his full
name is Azari t'challa and he's the son
of t'challa and storm a long time member
of the Axeman this version of the
character is actually from an alternate
future timeline from the mainline Marvel
Comics timeline Andy's a Teenage Mutant
who's inherited both his father's black
panther powers and his mother's power to
control lightning this of course is a
significantly different origin story
from the one wakanda forever's t'challa
Jr gets for starters he's still just a
small child when we meet him and we have
no idea whether he's inherited any of
the powers that were granted to his
father by wakanda's heart-shaped herb
though messing with a character's
background in live action adaptations
might annoy some fans it's
understandable that the MCU plays fast
and loose with t'challa's family tree
since storm hasn't been officially
introduced in the MCU and black panther
star Chadwick boseman's death in 2020
ended King t'challa's story there is no
way for the two to meet let alone start
a family meanwhile Nakia is t'challa's
former lover and obviously ongoing
romantic interest in Black Panther and
her linked the absence from the MCU
after the first Black Panther movie is
easily explained by the fact that she's
been in Haiti keeping the heir to a
Honda's Throne safe and hidden it's an
interesting move to introduce to
childless son at this exact point in the
MCU timeline not only does his existence
strongly hint that the Black Panther's
Legacy will continue even after shuri
but it also works wonders for her the
current black panther after all shuries
lost all the family members that she
knew of in relatively rapid succession
and is finally starting to resolve her
grief and Trauma by the time wakanda
forever ends the mid-credit scenes
Revelation that she's not the last
Living member of her family dovetails
perfectly with her character Arc of
accepting her losses and honoring her
family's Legacy black panther wakanda
forever is now in theaters
[Music]
foreign